[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau 7,8 l'hebdo l'émission de la
rédaction pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi à 3 novembre
découvrir un site et un sport olympique
près de 70 enfants accompagnés par le
secours populaire était ce vendredi au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
ils ont pu notamment s'essayer au bmx
thomas monteiro est notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission délégué
départemental de l'association pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité nous
évoquerons avec lui la très vaste
problématique de la fin de vie alors que
ce jeudi se tenait la 10e journée
mondiale pour le droit de mourir dans la
dignité
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale retour sur les festivités autour
d'halloween avec notamment un trailer
spécial organisé aux clayes-sous-bois je
vous le disais en titre favoriser
l'accès au sport et tenter de réduire
les inégalités 70 enfants ont découvert
ce vendredi le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mise en place
par la section locale du secours
populaire français
cette opération a permis à ces petits
chanceux de s'essayer aussi au bmx
nicolas d'andry à grégory canal est la
position fait pas comme centre c'était
une première pour la plupart de ces
enfants de 7 à 15 ans venus d'elancourt
de trappes ou encore de guyancourt
s'essayer au bmx vaincre peut-être une
peur et vibrer au rythme des bosses une
initiation d'abord en douceur avant de
tester pour les plus téméraires la piste
olympique qui accueillera l'entraînement
des athlètes pendant les jo 2024 en fait
d'une arnaque comme des traces ligne
lors on va essayer par ça entre eux avec
le guide on doit tourner comme des
zigzags on va réussir le mieux
alors on fait des bosses sans fin
on essaye de faire des bosses et trous
avec un vélo pour s'entraîner quoi pour
bat pour si on veut venir des
professionnels
il fallait vraiment prendre beaucoup de
l'élan après je pense que ça va y aller
c'était vraiment cool parce que ça
faisait une petite sensation y en a qui
ont un petit peu de difficulté à se
mettre debout déjà juste de synchroniser
le pédalage et de voir jusqu'où ils
peuvent aller pour pour franchir à une
bosse correctement sans sans danger
après le bmx les jeunes yvelinois ont
visité le vélodrome nationale une
journée découverte du site olympique
pour faciliter l'accès au sport moyen
d'expression et vecteur de lien social
pour le secours populaire des yvelines
c'est de rendre ici le sport pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les enfants
et les familles puisse s'évader du
quotidien et qu'ils puissent découvrir
des sports qui n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude de connaître dans l'après
midi les enfants ont pu rencontrer le
champion français de bmx et romain
racines avant d'assister à un
entraînement une journée qu'ils ne sont
pas prêts d'oublier
suite et fin du dossier de la rédaction
consacrée au marché de l'après vie avec
une victoire pour l'environnement et la
nature les produits phytosanitaires sont
interdits dans les cimetières depuis le
1er janvier 2017
les communes sont donc obligés de
réfléchir à de nouvelles méthodes pour
les entretenir la ville de versailles
s'est vu récompensé d'ailleurs récemment
pour sa politique environnementale dans
les cimetières la ville de saint cyr
l'école elle a entrepris des travaux
reportage de mélanie poké la nature
reprend vie autour des 12 milles
sépultures du cimetière des gones arts
de versailles
depuis 2009 la ville n'utilise plus de
pesticides dans ces quatre cimetières
ça implique non plus de chercher à
supprimer leur mois de la réintroduire
donc on a fait énormément dhr
gazonnement d'aller de trottoirs même on
a supprimé toutes les aides qui nous
prenait du temps tu avoir une réflexion
globale quand on travaille sur le zéro
pesticide c'est pas chercher à supprimer
l'air mais à la réintroduire
réintroduire le plus possible de végétal
payet systématiquement avec du broyat de
bois tous les arbustes les massifs
fleuris les les pieds d'arbres également
18 hectares d'espacés verts sont
aujourd'hui labellisé eco jardin du
gazon et planter des zones sont
revégétaliser là où le béton était
installé il y avait 1 anciennement
déclare vous qui avait été placé et donc
comme il y avait plus personne
tu qu'on a gardé cette cette partie
cette parcelle là pour pouvoir mettre
des vivaces dans ses partenaires avant
le zéro phyto 130 mille litres de
produits mélangés et ai répondu dans les
cimetières versailles est un pack a
aussi dû franchir la commune de saint
cyr l'école avec la loi la baie les
produits phytosanitaires sont interdits
depuis le 1er janvier 2017 dans l'ancien
cimetière 46000 euros ont été investis
dans des travaux un décapage complet
enlever la terre sur plusieurs
centimètres de profondeur pour enlever
les racines ensuite on area porté là
dessus de la terre végétale et on a
planté un gazon spéciale à pousse très
lente quand il sera terminé
ça sera une pousse très près serré qui
empêcheront des mauvaises herbes de
pousser un cimetière géré par un agent
des services techniques
c'est le plus grand des deux lieux de
sépulture de la commune avec près de
1000 concessions quand vous regardez la
taille des cimetières a lâché à la main
une par une c'était pas possible de le
faire
donc le fait d'en gazonné ici toutes les
années ça permettra de ne plus avoir ce
problème
l'autre cimetière c'est un peu différent
parce qu'il est
entièrement vers lui et il a été créé
pour ça dès le début malgré une place
prépondérante de la crémation les
cimetières gardent leur importance selon
un sondage 2015 des services funéraires
de paris 49% des français préfèrent les
lumas sion poursuivre sur cette
thématique nous allons désormais évoquer
un sujet qui ne cesse de faire débat en
france la question de la fin de vie
jeudi les pro euthanasie manifesté pour
la 10e journée mondiale pour le droit de
mourir dans la dignité et pour évoquer
cette très délicate question nous
recevons en plateau thomas monteiro
bonsoir on ça vous êtes thomas monteiro
délégué départemental dans les
hauts-de-seine de l'association pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité
évidemment vous êtes vous favorable à
l'euthanasie ce qui n'est pas autorisé
un légalement en france pour le moment
la dernière loi sur le sujet date de
2016 et depuis 2016 la france autorise
une sédation profonde et continue pour
les patients dont le pronostic vital est
engagé à court terme
concrètement on va un petit peu peut
être simplifié pour les gens il s'agit
d'un endormissement jusqu'à la mort du
du patient vous vous dites que ce qui a
été mise en place depuis 2016 cette
nouvelle loi n'est pas suffisante il
faut aller plus loin
oui bien sûr alors déjà pour parler de
la sédation profonde et quand il est pas
tout à fait d'accord avec ma avec ma
précision
non c'est pas vraiment ça mais disons
que la sédation profonde et continue
faut savoir que l'on meurt de faim et de
soif
on ne dit pas oui parce qu'en fait on va
expliquer le corps médical des branches
un peu tout ce qui maintient en vie et
ne nourrit plus et d'intrus
en fait on comment ça se passe en vous
endort en fait donc on vous met panne de
la morphine quelque chose comme ça donc
vous endormez vous allez plus vous
réveiller et ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
arrête en fait de vous hydrater et de
vous alimentez parce qu'on sait que
sinon vous allez pas mourir vous et moi
on est quand même assez jeune et assez
costaud en étant endormi on peut vivre
très longtemps si on prend pas donc le
cas de vincent lambert qui est assez
récent il a été endormi pendant plus de
30 jours et il était toujours pas mort
donc il ya quand même un réel problème
nous milices vraiment parce qu'il ya un
réel problème sur cette loi on meurt de
faim et de soif mais encore une fois si
un endormissement j'ai envie
dire que les gens n'ont plus conscience
de leur état de leur situation et qu'on
est peut-être là dans un compromis qui
peut être satisfaisant ou pas du tout
alors non pas du tout parce que déjà
tous les médecins qui nous disent qu'on
souffre pas dans une citation profonde
et continue sont des menteurs est-ce
qu'il ya aucune étude ni en france ni
dans le monde qui prouve qu'on ne
souffre pas dans une citation confondez
continuent leurs bêtes on n'en sait rien
on sait pas si les gens souffrent ou pas
donc c'est pour ça que nous on trouve ça
complètement aberrant qu'on n'est pas le
choix d'abord une euthanasie ou là on
est sûr et certain qu'on ne souffre pas
l'euthanasie ou suicide d'un suicide
assisté suicide assisté déjà on peut
peut-être préciser quelle est la
différence dans les deux cas c'est juste
c'est alors l'euthanasie c'est un tiers
en fait qui vous injecte le produit et
le suicide assisté c'est vous même qui
prenait le produit voilà donc ça peut
être sur un train par intraveineuse ça
peut être la solution locale fins et peu
importe mais en tout cas c'est vous qui
prévalait produit dans un suicide
assisté
il ya des gens et notamment des
spécialistes qui disent qu'aujourd'hui
la sédation profonde et continue
c'est presque la frontière est très
difficile à trouver finalement avec
l'euthanasie qu'on est presque à
l'euthanasie et que finalement pour
l'épreuve d'asie pourraient estimer que
c'est une victoire
est ce que vous vous estimez pas qu'on
est presque à l'euthanasie et que et que
finalement la joue un peu sur les mots
mais le résultat triste et malheureux
qui est la mort du patient et quoi qu'il
arrive abouti oui enfin de quelles
meures on parle on parle d'une mort de
faim et de soif
je pense pas qu'on verra en france on
est quand même dans le pays des droits
de l'homme
si on regarde en à la suisse belgique
luxembourg ils ont tous une loi sur la
fin de vie la belgique et sont très en
avance par rapport à nous sur toutes les
lois dites sociales
pardon si on reprend le mariage pour
tout ce qu'on peut comparer
éventuellement une loi de liberté comme
nous on propose il était en avance par
rapport à nous eh bien là c'est pareil
et ils ont même l'euthanasie pour les
mineurs donc c'est vous dire à quel
point ils sont en avance donc nous on
demande d'une loi à peu près comme la
loi belge qui ressemble c'est le modèle
justement je vais vous poser les
questions sur le modèle européen belge
qui plus tôt il faut soutenir selon vous
un débat sera lancé l'an prochain pour
les états généraux de la bioéthique
est-ce que vous pensez que clairement le
gouvernement français et puis les
français aussi puisque ça les concerne
directement sont prêts à bouger sur
cette ligne là est-ce que seulement un
an et demi après la nouvelle loi
léonetti classe et on est prêt à bouger
une nouvelle fois aller plus loin oui
oui parce que toute façon nous ont fait
beaucoup de sondages à la dmd il faut
savoir que depuis vingt ans les sondages
sont toujours les mêmes on pousse
toujours les mêmes questions et il ya
toujours le mot euthanasie dans cette
question d'âge avec le certains
d'ailleurs remettons oui bien sûr mais
comme toujours les sondages conscience
qu'on veut mais en attendant assez calme
une majorité écrasante savoir que plus
de 90 % des français sont favorables et
le noah sur l'euthanasie ils veulent
avoir le choix parce que savoir que nous
à la dmd en une association de liberté
on veut que chacun ait le choix et ce
soit le choix du patient à l'emploi de
ceux qui sont autour du lycée ça qui est
très important et il faut savoir qu'on
milite pour le choix de la personne
c'est à dire que si tu me persane et
contre on veux la respecter mais aussi
savoir que par exemple si on prend
l'étude de l'ined qui a été fait c'est
un institut très sérieux ils ont fait
une étude sur la fin de vie et faut
savoir qu'en france et à 4500 euthanasie
parents qui sont pratiqués 4500 alors
que cyril illégalement illégalement en
france et sur ses 4500 et aux nazis
seulement 0,2 pour cent des gens m'ont
demandé ce qui veut dire que il ya je ne
sais combien peu près de 3000 3400
personnes qui sont interdits en france
et qui n'ont pas demandé d'accord et
donc ça peut être aussi un contre
argument on peut dire non mais quand on
nous parle de dérive venir la dérive
années aujourd'hui en france il ya déjà
des dérivés du bien sûr et peut-être
s'il ya une loi le trac dérive c'est à
dire qu'il y aura il y aura un cadre
juridique à cela et nous attendent il
faut savoir qu'il ya des délais on s'est
pas séparé comme ça le matin l'hôpital
on veut mourir et puis non non pas du
tout c'est il ya des délais il ya des
médecins soient validées par deux
médecins
ça c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
on accompagne la personne chaque médecin
donne son avis sachant qu'un des deux
médecins qui ne vous connaît pas donc
c'est quand même quelque chose voilà on
pour revenir sur les déclarations
récentes de agnès buzyn la ministre de
la santé s est dit plus tôt elle
favorable à une évaluation de la loi
actuelle c'est vrai qu'elle est mise en
place seulement depuis je crois janvier
ou février 2016 à un peu plus d'un an et
demi presque parce que deux ans est-ce
que selon vous c'est vrai qu'encore en
est à très court terme la est-ce qu'il
faut tout de suite tour changer oui
alors on à la révision des lois
bioéthiques en 2018 vous en parliez tout
à l'heure
nous on espère que justement l'assemblée
nationale va bouger là dessus et qui va
y avoir une réelle loi sur la fin de vie
en profitant de cette révision des lois
bioéthiques
et puis si si les français sont
carrément favorable on le voit dans tout
dans tous les sondages et puis quand on
prenait fait un micro trottoir avec
votre micro sur un trottoir et demandez
aux gens vous parliez tout à l'heure du
mariage pour tous une question qui a
beaucoup divisé on le sait les les
français est ce que là aussi on risque
pas une nouvelle fois de peut-être
diviser les français sur des questions
qui sont profondément philosophique est
propre à chacun mais qu'est ce que c'est
un état deux derniers étages de livres
92 % des gens sont favorables à
l'euthanasie
donc ils veulent avoir la le choix de
pouvoir bénéficier
supposons que en 2018 on révise la loi
française et que l'euthanasie soit soit
autorisée va se poser la question du
périmètre c'est à dire du camp à quel
moment on décide que l'on peut autoriser
l'euthanasie sur sur une personne la
frontière c'est ça aussi le problème
principal aujourd'hui à quel moment on
peut décider que quelqu'un est assez
malade ac en souffrance comme en mesure
la souffrance de quelqu'un est ce qu'on
est capable soi même de mesurer la
souffrance pour décider de mourir c'est
pour ça que ce soit le choix du patient
déjà bon il ya quand même un critère
c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait une mort
certaine et à court terme
c'est le premier critère il faut qu'ils
aient bien sûr de la souffrance et il
faut qu'après la personne ne demandait
pas que ce soit les médecins ou les
héritiers qui décide pour la personne
faut que ça soit la personne donc il ya
une crainte aussi sur les abus c'est
vous qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
arguments ceux qui disent que si on
ouvre la porte à l'euthanasie après il y
aura forcément des abus vous parliez des
mineurs y en a qui disent que ce serait
impossible d'euthanasier des démineurs
sur sur cette question des abus ou là
aussi vous répondez quoi bein je leur
dit qu'elle était à des abus non je le
redis cas déjà des abus en france qui
regardent déjà ce qui se passe en france
oxygène aujourd'hui une autre une autre
question quand une fois je me fais pas
l'avocat des anti euthanasie j'essaye de
juste d'être un peu con tradicteur il ya
un débat philosophique qui est qui se
met en place qui consiste tout
simplement à dire on ne choisit pas le
moment halak auquel on arrive sur terre
la naissance est ce qu'on doit décider
celui auquel on parle mais comme le dit
si bien
notre président un présent de la dmd
jean luc romero en france il ya pas de
principes supérieurs dans une république
laïque qui oblige les gens à vivre le
plus longtemps possible et dans la
souffrance
je pense que ça répond assez bien votre
question une dernière question la dmd
vous êtes aussi favorable vous à l'accès
universel aux soins palliatifs sûr
est-ce que c'est pas là finalement le
principal point qui pourrait trouver un
consensus je suis sûr auprès de toute la
population que tout le monde ait accès
aux soins palliatifs ah oui c'est vrai
qu'il ya une très grosse inégalités déjà
deux territoires en france
savoir que sa mort ici on n'est pas dans
les régions les incidents urbanisées
seulement 20% des patients en france
bénéficient de sens créatif c'est
vraiment dramatique et à monsieur
leonetti qui est le monsieur fin de vie
de tous les gouvernements de droite et
de gauche à toutes les lois porte bien
sur ces voix là c'est lui qui a fait
toutes les lois sur la famille en france
il passe partout sur tous les plateaux
télé quand il était en responsabilité
pour dire oui oui comme je descends pas
et il faut des sens que les gens lisent
romero aujourd'hui oui mais en attendant
il s'en est pas occupé un nous militons
né dans la rue en était encore hier
place de la république pour soutenir
jean mercier qui lui a aidé sa femme à
mourir qui se retrouvent dans la cour de
cassation
voilà donc nous on fait quand même des
actions lui il parle beaucoup des
samples et natif maintenant 1 80% des
personnes qui constituent c'est là
évidemment évidemment bien sûr merci
thomas monteiro d'être venu en plateau
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le délégué
départemental pour les hauts-de-seine de
l'association pour le droit de mourir
dans la dignité il n'y a pas en ce
moment de délégués dans les yvelines
mais la question va être bientôt l'âge
l'échec lui même et le comprendre merci
à vous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
cette semaine marquée par le début de la
trêve hivernale jusqu'au 31 mars
prochain aucun locataire ne pourra être
expulsée de son domicile pour évoquer
cette actualité nous recevions mardi
deux membres d'associations qui agissent
pour l'accès au logement extraits
c'est indispensable sur un plan sur un
plan humain mais ça nous résout
strictement rien du problème du logement
il est exactement le même avant la trêve
hivernale
après la trêve hivernale et pendant la
trêve hivernale et on a probablement
tort de penser qu'il est plus facile de
vivre à la rue en été qu'en hiver
caroline très rapidement bah enfin je
rejoindrai faisait rare en fait c'est
enfin on a aujourd'hui un encombrement
du dispositif d'urgence et pourquoi il
ya un encombrement du dispositif
d'urgence et parce qu'un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont hébergés dans des
hôtels pourraient prétendre à un
logement social
or ya pas assez de logement social il
faudrait en construire on dit cinquante
mille par an pour voilà pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins de la population
française donc on est loin de ça et
comme il n'applique pas suffisamment la
loi sru non plus qui les oblige à avoir
20% de logement social par commune et
rien que dans les yvelines ya des écarts
assez important c'est toujours les mêmes
communes où se concentre le logement
social les moins dans les communes
riches voilà donc il ya un manque de
logement social qui entraînent un
engorgement du système d'urgence
c'était aussi les festivités autour
d'halloween comme tous les ans les
enfants sont partis à la chasse aux
friandises certains adultes eux on fait
du sport comme aux clayes-sous-bois la
ville a organisé son premier et treilles
l'halloween 400 sorcières et vampires
avait du coup rendez vous pour cet
événement reportage de miquel et demi
d'euros
sorcières chauve-souris morts-vivants
tenté ce mercredi 1er novembre la ville
des clayes-sous-bois pour participer à
ce premier trailer in de course à pied
au départ du parc jean carré y ont
imaginé par les organisateurs depuis le
mois de janvier dernier sur cette date
il y avait peu de courses dans la région
donc là comme yavé rien je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pas me glisser sur 7 sur
cette date du 1er novembre et ensuite le
trail idée du trail l'oin pour faire un
petit clin d'oeil à halloween
les deux sources à cette course
terrifiante proposé de la marche
nordique et des courses de 10 et 18 km à
travers les bois
un programme qui a séduit plus de 450
âmes perdues sur cette première édition
on a fait mal aux menhirs soir ça nous
empêche pas de fêter et puis on vient on
vient sans aucune appréhension à faire
18 tranquillement sort pas de problème
super idée on est et thématique c'est un
non franchement c'est très très bonne
idée on est hyper content d'être là
malgré la horde de monstres qui
l'entouraient pendant la course
christophe deprez a eu le coeur
solidement accroché pour remporter le 10
km en 39 minutes et 30 secondes
c'est vrai qu'il faut gérer entre les
côtes le plat donc je suis plus qu'un de
nos routes donc le plat malien les côtes
un peu plus dur mais bon à d'autres en
quatre derniers kilomètres j'ai pu finir
en première position
une fois l'apocalypse de la course passé
la matinée c'est évidemment terminée par
une dégustation d'une potion à base de
potiron
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
deuxième édition de ce trait lwin
cauchemardesque
[Musique]
et toujours en rapport avec halloween
quelques images plutôt sympathique des
animaux du refuge spa de plaisir
eux aussi ont participé vous le voyez à
la fête ils se sont déguisés pour
l'occasion
en attendant peut-être de trouver un
foyer
plus que quelques heures avant la fin
des vacances et alors que certains en
profitent pour se reposer d'autres sont
en pleine formation au centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux une
quinzaine de jeunes à passer le bafa
pour devenir ensuite animateur dans les
centres de loisirs la formation a duré
une semaine camille lambert a pu les
suivre lors de leur dernière journée de
formation reportage time's up qui est
qui houba l'américaine il vaut mieux
avoir plus d'enjeu dans son sac pour
occuper les enfants
si ces séances ressemble un peu une
récréation ces adolescents sont bien en
plein apprentissage
c'est le premier stage du cycle de
formation au bafa et il consiste en la
découverte des fonctions de l'animateur
qui sont donc abordé à travers des temps
de réflexion et des temps d'animation
sur les jours pour privilégier plutôt
des temps de réflexion qui leur
permettent de découvrir pas quels sont
les différents besoins des enfants selon
les tranches d'âge
comment s'organiser comme on gère la vie
quotidienne bien expliquer les règles
encadrent et être attentif aux
difficultés autant d'éléments à prendre
en compte pour devenir animateur une
quinzaine de jeunes se prête à
l'exercice avec plus ou moins
d'expérience j'ai fait beaucoup de colo
et d'accueil de loisirs quand j'étais
plus petit et j'aimais bien
j'aimais bien les animateurs j'ai trouvé
ça marrant et je sais pas ça m'a
toujours attiré 2 d'animer des enfants
de jouer avec eux qu'est-ce qui est
difficile de savoir expliquer par
exemple des animations trouvé le temps
de l'es2 les faire et à notre âge c'est
un peu compliqué et ce qui est facile
c'est en soi quand ta part tu mens on a
les petits frères des petites soeurs on
sera un peu comment s'en occuper j'ai
plutôt voulu participer parce que
j'entraîne au foot et du coup sa mort
sam apprenez à développer mes
connaissances sur les enfants quoi
seule condition pour passer son bafa
être âgé au minimum de 17 ans une
première étape quasiment validé pour ses
candidats
les futurs animateurs auront encore deux
stages à passer avant d'obtenir leur
brevet mardi une rencontre
intergénérationnelle était organisée au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 15 jeunes du
club de football local ont passé la
journée sur place en compagnie de 15 de
leurs aînés trappistes oui ce sont des
jeunes du club de football de trappes
au programme visite des lieux et
présence lors des répétitions d'un
spectacle
objectif de cette sortie organisée par
l'association pharma citoyens s'ouvrir à
d'autres disciplines et aussi renforcer
la solidarité propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude et miquel et
demi d'euros le foot est en réalité une
loisirs important mais également un
prétexte pour faire passer des messages
des messages importants celui de la
solidarité celui des valeurs de la
république on transmet dans chacun de
nos actes au quotidien de nos valeurs de
nos entraînements et aujourd'hui venir
au théâtre c'est une manière de dire il
ya le sport et à la culture tous qui
traverse un être et qui le fait grandir
et qui le fait s'ouvrir au monde
tentez à présent avec l'inauguration il
ya quelques semaines d'un nouveau centre
médical à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
basé sur le campus de guyancourt ce
centre accueille notamment deux messes
deux médecins généralistes et s'adresse
à tous et particulièrement aux étudiants
éloignés du domicile familial jeudi soir
nous recevions la directrice de ce
nouveau centre sur notre plateau
extraits
c'est une facilité d'accès aux soins
pour les étudiants pour la population
générale
évidemment aussi on sait que ça devient
compliqué donc c'est sympa donner un
coup de main aux médecins de la ville
et puis les étudiants oui parce qu'ils
les trouvent pas forcément des
rendez-vous disponibles et puis ceux qui
sont loin de chez leurs parents qui ne
rentrent que le week end
c'est bien qu'ils puissent avoir des
consultations de médecine générale en
semaine sur leur campus pour lui d'avoir
vu le médecin généraliste sur le lieu de
résidence de leurs parents d'avoir
directement sur place à l'université ça
facilite les choses
alors juste au niveau des équipements
vous avez deux bureaux équipés c'est ça
pour pour ces consultations
alors en fait le centre de santé il
ouvre dans le service médical que nous
occupions déjà d'accord au niveau de la
maison de l'étudiant marta pan dans
laquelle nous avons emménagé en juin
2016 donc ça s'est vu en cours
c'est à guyancourt sur le site de
guyancourt puisque l'université
multicity leçon de santé n'est que sur
ce site de guyancourt
effectivement il y a deux infirmières
qui travaillent avec lui depuis
longtemps dans le service de médecine
préventive et le centre de santé nous
sommes deux généralistes donc sur deux
cabinets différents au sein du service
après un mois d'octobre plutôt doux vous
l'avez sûrement remarqué le début du
mois de novembre marque le retour du
froid un élément qui peut endommager vos
jardins et plantes pour les préserver
quelques réflexes sont à connaître pour
l'hiver nicolas landry et hasna
allouache sont allés glaner quelques
conseils du côté des jardins de la
vallée à magny-les-hameaux
regardez qui a dit qu'il fallait
attendre les beaux jours pour jardiner
en ce début novembre l'automne
s'installe dans nos jardins et cela ne
rime pas forcément avec ramassage des
feuilles mortes
on peut s'en servir comme de terreau
dans les massifs c'est à dire les
souffrait dans les massifs et après
bêcher donc été incorporé en terre ça
permet de créer un engrais vert
finalement voilà et donc est donc de
l'humus à terme
et donc de l'engrais pour vos plantes
dans les massifs je suis étonné encore
le froid mais lui pas aux plantes un
végétal ne réagit pas du tout comme un
humain c'est pas parce qu'il fait froid
pour nous que le végétal à froid lui au
contraire c'est vraiment l'époque où il
va émettre ses racines
voilà donc il a besoin de cette période
de dormance
autre surprise de tonnes certaines
plantes sont encore en fleurs on prend
son mal en patience c'est quand même
dommage de se séparer de deux de
floraison actuellement l on va les
laisser tranquilles enfin le mois de
novembre
c'est aussi la période de plantation de
certains arbres fruitiers comme les
peaux millions mais attention pour les
faire fructifier
l'emplacement est important on va
rechercher un minimum de soleil quand
même pour que la fructification se fasse
se fasse bien et surtout que le bourgeon
au printemps quand il est clos soit au
maximum au soleil pour essayer d'animer
les toutes petites joli jeu ce qui est
important c'est de forcément de bien
orienter son son sujet et bien sûr de
regarder que le col et c'est à dire la
base de la plante soit au niveau du sol
a ajouté une dose engrais naturel et il
n'y a plus qu'à attendre le printemps
pour la floraison
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information en direct à 18 heures
sur les antennes lundi en direct à 18
heures sur les antennes de tv 78 d'ici
là restez informés et connecté grâce à
nos applications tv 78 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]